ก็สวัสดีค่ะน้าสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ค่ะสวัสดี
นักเรียนครับผม
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีอีกรอบค่ะโอเคแล้วนะคะ
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันวันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์
หน้าวันอาทิตย์ทรายนะครับวันที่เท่าไหร่
ครับขออันนี้วันอาทิตย์ที่ 7 ครับหน้าวัน
อาทิตย์ที่ 7 มาเรียภาษาไทยกันค่ะอ่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะถ้าเนื้อนี้เดือนนี้เดือนนี้
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับนิจิกายนนะคะปีพตเท่าไหร่คะ
ปีพศษส
ครับ 5  4 หั่น
564 ล้านไม่ใช่แล้วต้องครับพี่ข้อสอบ
เท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2000  21 ครับสองพันสองพัน
21-25
[เพลง]
กูอันตี้วันนี้ทางรายดีนะคะแข็งแรงดีกว่า
ที่แข็งแรงดีครับวันนี้กินข้าวหรือยังวัน
ที่กินข้าวแล้วกินแล้วครับแล้วแล้วนะอิ่ม
แล้วอิ่มแล้ว
กินหรือยังครับครูเอ๋กินนิดหน่อยอ๋ออ๋อ
กินนิดหน่อย
เอ๋กินอาหารหน่อย
นิดหน่อยแล้วอิ่มไหมครับ
ทีนิดหน่อย
เพราะว่ากินแล้วไม่อร่อยอ่ารอบอร่อยถ้า
บอกไม่อร่อยถึงอยากกินผลไม้อ๋อก็อยากกิน
ผลไม้อ่าเอ้ออยากกินผลไม้น้าอ้าวแล้วนิด
หน่อยค่าอยากกินผลไม้อีกนะครู App ที่มี
ผลไม้ให้ครูเอ๋กินไหมหาครัวตี้มีผลไม้วัน
นี้
มั้ย
ให้กูเอ๋ดูให้นักเรียนนักเรียนดูผลไม้ดู
ให้นะครูเอ๋นะคิดอยากกินผลไม้ครู Arty มี
ผลไม้ให้ครูเอง do
i
r มีผลไม้อะไรคะครูอาจๆผลไม้
อย่างแรกอย่างที่ 1 อ่านี่ครับอ่าเป็น
ผลไม้
แต่ให้อะไรคะขออัดผลไม้อะไรใช่ไหมครับนี่
เป็นอะไร
ผลไม้ชื่อ
สับปะรด
สับปะรดให้เขากลับปะรถเท่าไหร่คะสับปะรด
มีทั้งหมด 1 ลูกครับ 1 รูป 5 สับปะรด 1
ลูกเคสับปะรดแน่โดนหันเอาไว้เป็นหนึ่ง
อะไรคะนั้นอ่ะ 1 ชิ้นหน้ารถ 1 ชิ้นหน้า
หายราคาก็มีสับปะรดทั้งหมด 1 ลูกได้ค่ะ
ท่านออกมา
1 ชิ้น1ชิ้นสีอะไรคะครู Arty สับปะรด
สับปะรดสีเหลืองครับนี้
ศีล 5
ศีลข้อนี่สีเหลืองอ่าร้านเหลืองครับ
ร้านครูแอ๊ดที่ชอบกินสับปะรดไหมคะกลัวตี้
ชอบพ่อกินสับปะรดครับเวลาเอาสับปะรดเข้า
ปากแล้วก็เคี้ยว 5 เป็นยังไงคะมีน้ำ
สับปะรดถ้ามีน้ำสับปะรดมีน้ำครับมีน้ำ
หวานหวานๆเปรี้ยวเนาะ
นะอิอิหาครู Arty ชอบนะคะครูเอ๋ก็ชอบ 5
ครับตีคิดว่านักเรียนชอบสับปะรดไหมคะอ้า
นักเรียนชอบสับปะรดไหมครับขวดที่ชอบคือ
เอ๋ก็ชอบนักเรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนชอบไหม
ครับนักเรียนเขียนเขียนนะคะเขียน
ที่ comment  comment ใช่ด้านล่างนะครับ
ข้อสอบครูชอบ Read ไม่ชอบอ่ะถามเอ๋แล้ว
ชอบมากๆโอ้โหขวดอีกรอบชอบ
เหมือนกันนะโอเคหา
อยากกินสับปะรดใช่ไหมกินสับปะรดกูเองหิว
มีผลไม้อื่นไหมคะสับปะรดแรงไหมคะกว่าที่
สับปะรดไม่แพงครับไม่แพงใช่ครับหนึ่งลูก
ประมาณกี่บาทคะ 5  1 รูปประมาณ 30 บาท
ได้ครับตาม 10 บาทน่ะเดี๋ยวพี่อ่ะครู Arty
เกี๋ยนให้ดูๆตรงนี้
ตา 30
บาท 5  30 บาท 1 ลูกนะคะเดินป่า 1 ลูกนะ
คะ
แปลกๆถ้านักเรียนไปที่ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตแพง
นะคะ
แพงกว่าแพงกว่านี้อ่ะถ้าซื้อ
30 บาทซื้อที่ไหนคะ R  30 บาทซื้อที่
ตลาดอ่ะ
ใจครับ Thai  market นะของคนไทยนะคะใช่
ครับ 10 บาทนะอ้าได้ร้านกูหน้าครับต่อไป
ค่ะมีไม่มีผลไม้อื่นมีผลไม้อีกครับหน้า
ผลไม้อันนี้นี่
มีสีเขียวเจ้าไหมสีแดงชายครับมีสีเขียว
นี่ตรงนี้สีเขียวค่ะสีแดงนี่นะคะนี่
ครับผลไม้นี่ชื่ออะไรคะเนื้อหาผลไม้นี้
ผลไม้นี้คนไทยเรียบแตงโมโพสต์แตงโม้
ใช่ครับแตงโมเนี่ยโอ้โหลูกใหญ่เนาะรู้
ใหญ่ได้
มีลูกใหญ่
เวลาอ๋อมีแตงโมทั้งหมดเท่าไหร่คะมีแตงโม 1
ลูกน่ะตรงนี้ 1 ลูกก็มีแตงโมตรงนี้อีก 1
ชิ้นอ๋อมีแตงโม 1 ลูกกับ 1 ลูกแล้วก็ลืม
ชิ้นนี้ครับงั้นเวลากินแล้วก็หยิบ 1 ชิ้น
มากัดทรายๆอีกแล้วนี่กัดได้เลยไม่น้ำหวาน
ไหลออกมาว่าอาหารหิวหิวหิวอีกแล้วยากินยา
กินแตงโมโอ้โหเชียงใหม่ครับโอเคอยากกิน
ผลไม้
ครูอาร์ทบิ๊กช็อปกินแตงโมไหมคะอ่ะครัวติ
ชอบกินแตงโม
มากกว่ามากกว่าสับปะรด
ชอบกินแตงโมมากกว่ามากกว่าสับปะรดสับปะรด
ไปครับหน้าเหมือ
นาจะชอบแตงโมแตงโมเอะมากกว่าเหมือนกันออก
มาให้ปลูกเหรอ
โอเคโอเคชอบสับปะรดมากป่าแตงโม
on  OK ปวดดีชอบแตงโมมาความช้อปเปอร์รถ
นักเรียนนะคะชอบแตงโมหรือชอบสับปะรด R
อะไรไหนมาขอราคาอายครับถ้ากู Arty แปลง
หมดแรงไหมแตงโมแตงโมแพงกว่าแพงกว่า
สับปะรดท่าไหนโม้
ราคาเท่าไหร่คะแตงโม 1 ลูก 1 ลูก 80 บาท
ให้ครับ 50 บาทจ้าได้ 1 ลูกนั้นน่ะนะน่ะ
ใช่ครับแตงโมน่ะน่ะ
หนักประมาณกี่กิโลกรัมแตงโมนัทประมาณ 2
กิโลกรัม 2 กิโลกรัมครับประมาณ 2
กิโลกรัมนายหาประมาณกรัมแต่งอ้าลูกใหญ่
กอล์ฟแพงกว่าแพงกว่ามีแตงโมสีเหลืองด้วย
นะหนังอาร์ไทยมีแตงโมสีเหลืองด้วยอานิ
แป้งโมมีสีสีแดงแล้วก็อันนี้เป็นสีแดงมี
แตงโมสีเหลืองชายครับไปทัวร์ติชอบชอบแตง
โมสีแดง
ๆอ่านะอร่อยนักเรียนนักเรียนชอบแต่งโบว์
มั้ยหน้ารอบ
ถ้าชอบก็ข้างล่างนะอ่าผมชอบแตงโม
บอกครูด้วยนะคะถ้าได้ครับรูก็อยากรู้นะคะ
เนี่ยชอบแตงโมไหมเอา
สับปะรดครูเอ๋ชอบมากแตงโม OA ก็ชอบผลไม้
อื่นอีกไหมคะคูามีผลไม้อื่นอีกครับมีมี
อะไรคะต่อไปเป็น
นี้นี่ B
คะ
อันนี้
อันนี้กูเอชอบมากที่สุดก็
ไม้มากยาวเลยมากรถอันนี้ขอนี้ชอบมากมาก
ที่ 10 ใช่ไหมชอบมาก
ๆอันนี้มีคือ
มะละกอมะละกอมะละกอ
สุกเนาะๆครับมารับก่อนสู่ a หิว
อยากกินมาละกออยากกิน
ข้าวกินสับปะรดอ่ะฮ่าๆ
สับปะรดอยากกินแตงโมอย่าชิ้นมาละก่อนหา
กินมากที่ไหนมะละกอ
ครูอาร์ติสต์ชอบกินมะละกอไหมคะกลัวตีชอบ
กินมะละกอ
อีกนิดนึงชอบเพียงรกรนิดนึง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ถ้าไม่มีถ้าไม่มีถ้าไม่มีผลไม้ควรที่ก็จะ
กินอ๋อแต่ถ้ามีแตงโมควยตี้ก็จะกิจแบ่งหมก
ไม่กินมะละกอถ้าไม่ถ้าไม่มีแตงโมมี
สับปะรดกับปีมาต่อ
ตีก็กินสัปปะร้อน
โอเค
มันกอดที่
รักอ่าอันที่หนึ่งเครียดแล้วก็มีอะไรคะ
อันไหนมะละกอตรงนี้อ่ะ CD  M  R แหม
อ่าสีดำน่าอ่านเมล็ดสีดำตรงนี้เมล็ดสีดำ
ครูเอ๋กินไหมครับจีไหมไม่กินค่ะถ้าไม่เอา
ไป Red สีดำไม่กินแก
A5 ๆกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋คิดว่ากินไม่ได้นะพิมพ์ไม่ได้ใช้
ครับอาหารเราไม่อิ่มรบกวนตีนกูเอกคิดค่า
กินเมล็ดสีดำลงไปเดี๋ยวมีมะละกอนะ
ซักออกขึ้นมาขึ้นมาจากของจริง
กินไม่ได้เมล็ดกินได้แล้วกินตรงไหนคะอ้า
เรากินตรงนี้ครับว่าเนื้อใช่ครับกินเนื้อ
เนื้อมะละกอกินได้
เมล็ดไม่กินเราหาพี่เนื้อมะละกอ
เปลือกกินไหมคะเหลือก็ไม่กินครับเปลือก
นี้มีเบื่อนี่ไม่กินไม่กินใช่ครับอ่ะมา
รับต่อเราไม่กิน
ได้เราไม่ใช่ครับ
เนื้อมะละกอกินเนื้อมะละกอสีส้มตรงนี้ห้า
เนี่ยมาก่อนส้มน่ากินเสื้อน้ำลายสายลายจะ
เห็นแล้วล่ะ
ย่าตินว่าเดี๋ยว
ไปมีคนละไม้อีกคนละวรรณะวีอีกหนึ่งมีอะไร
ครับเนี่ยไรไงโอ้โหอันนี้
พี่ผลไม้ฝรั่งครับฝรั่งฝรั่ง
คู๋ชอบกินฝรั่งไหมโอเคขอชอบคอกนิดหน่อย
อ่า
โอเค
ฝรั่งโอเค
ไปกินโอเคอ่าอ่าโอเค
ฮัลโหลเหมือนครู Arty เห็นมะละกออ๋อชอบ
นิดหน่อย
นะคะๆอ้างสีสีเขียวสีเขียวครับเขียวนะคะ
อ่ะอ่ะครู Arty ชอบกินฝรั่งไหมคะ 5 ขวด
อี้ชอบกินฝรั่งชอบกินฝรั่งแค่นี้
ก็กินมะละกอแค่นี้
เค้ากินแตงโมแค่นี้แต่งงงมาก
ครับกินมะละกอนิดหน่อยกิน
โอเค
ฝรั่งดีนะกูอะตี้ขอใช่ครับเปล่าแม่มีไว้
จะ minzy
มีไวตามินซีมากๆรักษาๆแหมกูเอกกินฝรั่ง
คู่เอกกิน
พรุ่งนี้ไหมครับมีไซส์หรอคะอ่ะชายครับไส้
แล้วก็มีเมล็ดอะไรไม่กินอ๋อไม่กินอ่ะกลัว
ที่ก็ไงนะอ๋อกินแต่เนื้อตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ฝรั่งนะคะตรงนี้อ่าโอเคกูออกไปแล้วคะรับ
ครัวตีก็กินกินเนื้อแล้วก็เมล็ดไม่กิน
เหมือนกันมั้ยกินนะอ้าเราสองคนไม่กินไส้
แล้วก็มีเมล็ดไม่กินกินแตกนึงละฝรั่งแต่
คนอื่นคนอื่นกินได้หน้าใส่กับบางคนก็กิน
ได้แต่ครัวตี้ไม่กินคู๋ไม่กินใช่อ่าอ่า
จริงๆเวลาครูเอ๋เด็กๆ in กินเมล็ดอ่า
เลยกินแต่ว่า
คุณพ่อคุณแม่บอกห้ามกิน
[เพลง]
ทั้งสิ้นก็เลยโดนตีขอน้ำกินถ้ากินไม่ให้
กินนะคะ
มาแล้วกูเอกกินเปลือกไหมครับกินเลือกไหม
อ้าวฝรั่งกินหรือได้อีกได้ใช่มั้ยอ้ะได้
เรือน่ากิน
ทิ้ง
กินได้เลยกินได้หากินได้เลยอ๋อโอเคอ้า
แล้วอันนี้อันนี้กูเห็นรู้จักไหมครับวัน
นี้อะไรครับใบฝรั่งค่ะอ้อใบฝรั่งน่ะเป็น
ใบไปให้กินข้าวไม่กินกิน
แล้วติดกับใบเรียกว่าอะไรคะติดกับใบตรง
นี้เหรอครับคั่วไหมอ่าใช่ครับเป็นขั้ว
ขั้วที่ออกมาจากฝรั่งไม้ควบลูกปะหล่ำบ้าง
เต็มๆหน้ามีขั้วนี้เป็นต้นอ่ะไม่กินคั่ว
ก็ไม่ใช่กินข้าวใช่ไม่กินใบก็ไม่กินไม่
กินนะคะอ้าเมตรก็ไม่กินเราไม่กิน
เราเราคือครูเอ๋เอ๋กูอัดนี่ล่ะเราไม่กิน
ไม่กินใช้เรียนกินไหมหากินเม็ดไหมไม่เห็น
กินแม่
นักเรียนบอกครูหน่อย
ว่ากินไหมค่ะราคาอ่ะมีผลไม้อีกไหมคะเผื่อ
มีผลไม้ดีผลไม้อีกนะครับอ่านี่ไงอันนี้
เอกก็ชอบเหมือนกันใช่ไหมครับชอบวันที่
อันเนี้ยน้ำลายกำลังจะไหล
น้ำลายสิ่งทุกอย่างเลยไปไปทุกอย่างเพราะ
ว่าหิวใช่ไหมอ่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วเนี่ยสีเขียวเนี่ยครับจะ
ได้ครับเวลาเราจะกินผลไม้เปรี้ยวเราก็จะ
น้ำลายก็จะไหลใช่ไหม
อะไร
ก็ขวดเตี้ยผลไม้ทิพย์คนไทยเรียกมะม่วงมา
ม่วนมะม่วงใช่ครับมะม่วงมะม่วงเรารักๆ
มะม่วงมีสีเขียวกับสีแดงเหลืองส้มๆๆ
อันนี้เป็นมะม่วงสีเขียวเพราะว่ามะม่วง
เพราะว่าอะไรคะมะม่วงดิบๆ 555 ให้มะม่วง
ดิบสีเขียว
เหลืองล่ะคะถ้าเป็นสีเหลืองเป็นมะม่วงสุก
มีมะม่วงมี 2 แบบมะม่วงดิบกับมะม่วงสุก
อายครับเดี๋ยวสีเหลืองกว่าตีชอบกินมะม่วง
ดิบอ่ะหรือมะม่วงสุก 5 ขวดปีชอบกินมะม่วง
ดิบอ๋อ
เปรี้ยวได้ครับเพราะว่ามะม่วงดิบจะ
เปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวอาไปทำมะม่วงสุกมะม่วงสุก
จะเปรี้ยวไหมครับไม่เบี้ยวค่ะเปรี้ยว 5
ม้วน
สารหน้าตายครับ
ตัวตีชอบกินมะม่วงเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวเก๋ชอบ
มะม่วงสุกมากกว่ามะม่วงดิบหอ
ก็ชอบมะม่วงฮ่าฮ่า
ๆๆครับกลัวตีก็ชอบมะม่วงมะม่วงแค่นี้อ่ะ
ดีมากกว่ามากกว่าฝรั่งทำไมอ่ามะละกออ้า
มากกว่ามะละกอ
กูแอปที่อาบมีมะม่วงกี่ลูกคะมีมะม่วงสาม
ลูกครับข้าวนะคะ 3 ลูกแล้วก็สามีมะม่วง 3
ลูกมะม่วงเนี่ยแครงไหมคะผัว Arty มะม่วง
มะม่วงไม่แพง 5
กิโลกรัม 1 กิโลกรัมประมาณเท่าไหร่คะอ่ะ 1
กิโลกรัมประมาณ
40 บาท
40 บาทพลฑิตนะอ่ะนะคะๆใช่ครับมะม่วงดิบ
ครูปาร์ตี้ครูเอหรือมันถามฝรั่งฝรั่งไป
ฝรั่งก่อนฝรั่งใช่ไหมฝรั่งอันนี้มีมีมี 1
ลูกมี 1 ลูกแล้วก็มีอีก 2 ชิ้นอันนี้หิน 1
2  inch ใช้กอล์ฟโลก
ฝรั่งเนี่ยแพงไหมคะอ้าฝรั่งกลัวตี้คิดว่า
คิดว่าไม่แพงไม่แพงอ่า
ฝรั่งอากิรอละถ้าฝรั่งอันนี้ 1 กิโลกรัม
ประมาณ 5  1 เกิดนำประมาณ
ประมาณเท่าไหร่นะครับโอเคเดลิเวอรี่ 45
บาทอ๋อมันผิด 5 บาทใช่ไหมกลัวตีไปซื้อที่
ตลาดกิโลล้าน 25 บาท
ใช่ครับ 25 บาทไปตลาด
โลละ 25 บาทเสียนะว่าตี้บางอ่าโอเคกิโลละ
25 บาทถ้าไม่แพ้โด 1 กิโลกรัมมีกี่ลูก 1
กิโลกรัมมี
เลิกงานประมาณ
3-4 รูปคู่น่าจะนะครับน้ำแครงๆอาจไม่แพง
ไม่ใช่กูอตี้แต่ถ้าข้างในฝรั่งสีชมพู
โอ้โห
ๆตั้งในสีชมพูแพง up ไม่ค่อยมีไม่ค่อยมี
ขาย 1 กิโลกรัมเนี่ย
120 บาทครบแอร์ขวดตี้หัวตี้กินมะม่วงดี
กว่า
มะม่วง 40 บาทใช่มั้ยครับอ่าโอเคอ้อมาพวก
1 กิโลกรัม 40 บาทนะคะใช่ครับเมื่อกี่ลง
เปรียว
โอ๊ยหิวจังเลยกูอ่ะหิวมากแล้วตอนนี้หิว
มากแล้วซะแล้วคิดว่าเดี๋ยวคลิปนี้เสร็จ
วิ่งไปซื้อมะม่วง
คะมะละกอสับปะรด 5 ฝรั่งอ่ะฝรั่งไม่ซื้อ
ซื้อไหมคิดดูก่อนคลิบเท่าไหร่อีกอ่อนฉิบ
หานะๆมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะครูอันนี่มี
ผลไม้อีกทั้ง up ที่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยมี
ผลไม้ทำเยอะมากใช่ครับมีนี่ครับศรีพี่
ฮ่าๆ
ชอบอีกแล้วคุยตอบ
อยากกินเจอาร์
ชื่ออะไรครับอันนี้ชื่อลำไยครับลำใย
ชอบกินลำไยไหมชอบกินใหญ่ไหมครับชอบๆๆทำ
ใหญ่เท่ากับสับปะรด
ซอฟต์ลำไยเท่ากับสับปะรด
องค์ประกอบมากกว่า
ชอบมะละกอที่สุดใช่ไหม
ที่สุดหน้า
ลำไยหวานนะหาใช้ครับลำใยหวาน
สีอะไรคะเนื้อลำใหญ่สีขาวเนื้อลำใยเนื้อ
ลำไยสีขาวมีสีขาวใช่ครับมีรสหวานหวานเม็ด
ลำไยสีอะไรคะเหตุลำไยนี่สีดำกินได้ไหม
ครับใหญ่สีดำกินไม่ได้กินไม่ได้กินไม่ได้
กินเนื้อกินเนื้อนะครับหน้าแล้วก็เปลือก
ลำไยสีอะไรคะเปลือกลำไยสีนี้สีน้ำตาลให้
ครับเปลือกลำไยสิตาลมีสีน้ำตาลกินได้ไหม
ครับคู่เอกกินเผื่อไม่ให้ไหมให้กินขวดตี
ก็ไม่กินกินไม่ได้ถ้ากินไม่ได้นะเผื่อลำ
ใยไม่ได้นะคะก็กินไม่ได้
กินไม่ได้กินเนื้อนี่กินเนื้อใช่ค่ะหวาน
อันตีสตรงนี้มีลำไยกี่ลูกคะเนี่ยะลองนี่
ทำใจ 1 ลูกมีลำไย 1 ลูกตรงนี้อีกครึ่งลูก
มีลูกกับครึ่งลูกรวมกันก็เป็นเหนือไปอ๋อ
ซึ่งลู่อันนี้พึ่งลูกรวมกันเป็นหนึ่งลูก
ขึ้นมหาลัย 2 เล่ม 2 ลูก
รูแฮปปี้ใจแพงไหมลำไยลำไยแพงแพงกว่า
มะม่วง
ลำไยกิโลกรัมละกิโลกรัมละเท่าไหร่คะหนึ่ง
ประมาณประมาณ 100
4  50 บาท
โน้ตแพงเนาะเนี่ยแต่ว่ามีหลายลูกลำไยรูป
เละน้ำยังไงรูปเล็กใช่ครับหน้ารำไยเป็น
ลูกอย่างนี้แล้วก็มีใช่ไหมค่ะอ้าลำไยรุ่ง
เล็กใช่เป็นควงน่ะหน้าหลายรูปหนึ่งกำก็มี
ลำไยลายดีมากผู้ใคร ahh
ที่อยู่แล้วที่อยู่แล้วครับหน้า
มีอีกอย่างหนึ่งอันนี้นักเรียนทุกคนต้อง
เคยกินเคยกินแน่ๆ
นี้นี้นี้เอาอะไรคะ 5 นี้เดี๋ยวนะกวนตี
กำลังจะเปิดให้โอ้นี่ไง
หาย
อานิคนไทยเรียกว่ากล้วยครับกล้วยหา
ยาวมีชื่อรวยยาวันนี้ลูกยาวกล้วยยาวนี้
เรียกว่ากล้วยหอมกล้วย
หอมใช่ครับกินกล้วยหอมไหมคะน่ากลัวแต่
ชอบกินกล้วยหอมครับอ๋อชอบกินกล้วยหอมแค่
นี้เขา
แค่หนีตอบมะม่วงมากกว่าชอบแตงโมมากกว่า
อ่ะเอ้ากินกล้วยออกแค่นี้โอเคแล้วครูเอ๋
แล้วครับคู๋ชอบไหมชอบกินกล้วยหอมมั้ยไม่
ชอบกินเหรอไปกิน
ทำไมครับทำไมไม่กินกูเองไม่ชอบรวยหอม
ตั้งเวลาได้กลิ่นกล้วยหอมไม่เอาไม่อ๋อม
เหรอไว้หอขอไม่เอาไม่ออก
กูเองไม่กินกล้วยหอมค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่กินกล้วย
หอมนะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนกิน
กล้วยหอมไหมครับนะฮะ Tour ตี้กินนักเรียน
กินไหมครับครูเอกคิดนักเรียนกล้วยหอม
ขวดพี่ก็คิดว่านักเรียนก็กิน
แต่คู่เอกไม่กินให้
กูเอกเลยกูเอกกินสับปะรดกินมะละกอกิน
มะม่วงไหมครับกินฟ้าหลั่งแต่ไม่กินกล้วย
หอมๆครูเอ๋ไม่กินกล้วยหอม
กว่าตี้กินทุกก็สวัสดีกินทุกอย่างนะครับ
ชอบกล้วยหอมประมาณนี้หาใช่ครับชอบคุยกับ
หอมแค่นี้อ่ะชอบไม่มาไม่หิวล่ะ
เห็นกล้วยหอมไม่หิวแล้วโอเคทีมมีอะไรอยาก
กินอะไรอยากกินนะคะและกล้วยหอมสีเหลือง
เนาะสีเหลืองๆครับกล้วยหอมสีเหลืองอ่า
โค๊ดอี้กล้วยหอมมีกี่ลูกโอ้โหโอ้ยหอมกลัว
ตี้เห็นเห็นกล้วยหอมมี
r&r 9 ลูกอะไรนะเราลูกไหมนะ
นะประกากลัวตี้อ่า 9 ลูกหนี้
1  2 อันนี้สาว
We  Are  6  7  8  9  7  9 ลูกเพราะมีมี
นี้กล้วยหอมอันนี้อ้าไม่มีเปลือกไม่มี
เผื่อหรออีก 1 ลูกเป็น 10 ลูกนะครับ 50
โลกแล้วแล้วกล้วยหอมที่หยุดติดกันนะค่ะ
อ่ะเราเรียกว่าหนึ่งอะไรล่ะคะหน้านี้เป็น
ชิ้นนี่ 1 ชิ้นสองชิ้น 3 ชิ้นนะ
6  7  8  9 อยู่รวมกันเรียกว่ากล้วยหอม
นึงหวี 555 หนึ่งหวีทรายครับหน้าหนึ่งหวี
นะคะผู้หากูอะตี้กล้วยหอมได้เป็นชิ้นหรือ
เป็นรูปเป็นหวีอ้าตัวตีขึ้นเป็นลูกครับ
เพลงโลกใต้กลัวแต่ไม่ต้องก็ไม่ต้องอาหาร
เป็นชิ้นกลัวติกัดกินเลยอ่ะอ่ะอ่ะกันเลย
อ่าลูกสองไร่ครับคะ 2 ลูกโอ๊คกินไม่ไหว
เยอะเกิดกินไม่หมดไม่หมดให้ครับถึงลูก
แล้วลูกๆลูกใหญ่
ร้อนจะกิจต้องปอกปอกเปลือกด้วยเฮ้ยเฮ้ย
หวัดดีต้องปอกเปลือกเปลือกกินไม่ได้ค่ะ
กินไม่ได้ต้องตอบเปิดเป็นแบบนี้แล้วก็น่า
กันกินนะคะถ้า
ครู Arty ครับไม่ชอบไปๆ
หมดแล้ววันนี้ผลไม้ๆหมดแล้ว R  R  R
ผลไม้หมดแล้วนะคะอ่ะไม่มีผลไม้แล้วงั้น
ครูเอ๋ต้องออกไปหาหาซื้อผลไม้
เอาไปซื้อก็รวยใช่ไหมกล้วยหรือเปล่าเค้า
ไม่เอากล้วยไปซื้อมาละก่อนใช่ไหมใช่ช่าง
ข้างๆบ้านหาเอ๋มีรถเข็นอ่ะพ่อมีรถเข็นขาย
ผลไม้
สวัสดีที่มีรถเข็นผลไม้ให้นักเรียนดูนี้
นี่ไงทำไม้ไชโยมีผลไม้อะไรมั่งครับมี
ผลไม้อะไรบ้างครับพี่เอ๋มีสับปะรด
นี่สับปะรดครับมีสหรสที่มีอะแตงโมแตงโม
โกลด์แอล
มีอะไรอีกครับมีมะละกอมีนี่ไงที่กูเอกปอบ
พิมพ์มากที่สุดเลยค่ะนัดก็
เห็นสีเขียวฝรั่งไม่ไงครับห้าใช่ครับนี่
ฝรั่ง
ซีรีย์ฝรั่งไม่ทำมีฝรั่งหั่นเป็นชิ้นชิ้น
แล้วอ่านเป็นสินใจเต็มแล้วก็ๆที่มีไม้
จิ้มไม้จิ้มแล้วก็กินได้เลยค่าแล้วก็มี
มะม่วงตรงนี้เป็นมะม่วงไงครับมีน้ำมูกมี
มะม่วงนะคะคู่เห็นในถุงในกะละมังยใกล้ๆ
ผู้หญิง
อันนี้หรอกครับในนั้นเป็นเป็นเค้าเรียก
อะไรนะเกราะคนข้างในมีน้ำจอใต้มีน้ำจิ้ม
ไปครับจิ้มคนไทยจะกินสับปะรดแล้วก็จิ้ม
น้ำจิ้มแล้วก็กินได้ครับฝรั่งแล้วก็จิ้ม
น้ำจิ้มเขาก็กิน
มะม่วงจิ้มน้ำจิ้มแล้วก็กินอะไรเหงาไม่
จิ้มไม่จิ้มอ่ะแตงโมมีแตงโมงก็ไม่จิ้มนะ
คะถ้าราคา
โอ้ยกู Arty คู๋หิวหนูอีกแล้วกลับมาหิว
อีกแล้วหิวหิวถึงหิวมาก
เห็นเห็นๆรถเข็นผลไม้ของขวัญที่ก็ได้คิด
ถึงรถเข็นผลไม้อะไรๆบ้านนะครับคิดว่าครู
เอ๋น่ะต้องไปซื้อซื้อใช่มั้ยไปซื้อผลไม้
รถเข็นผลไม้ไม่แพงนักเรียน 1 ถุง 5 ทราย
ครับ
ตายๆๆ
ตีนี่ไหมคะมีครับใกล้ๆบ้านกลัวนี่ก็มีรถ
เข็นผลไม้แบบนี้อ้าถุงเท่าไหร่คะ 1 ถุง 20
บาทใช่ครับ 20 บาทได้ 1 ชิ้น1ชิ้น 20 บาท
ใครครับไม่คะอ่าไม่อิ่มแล้วกูอะตีนต้อง
ซื้อกี่ใต้ต้องซื้อ 2 ถุงมาซื้อสับปะรด
แล้วก็ซื้อแตงโมหน้าก็ตีไม่ซื้อมาละก่อน
ฮ่าๆ o  o  s  o
แต่ว่าตอนมีนิดหน่อยนะนักเรียนอ่ะเวลาเอก
ไปซื้อมะละกอก็ไม่มีหมดแล้วอ้ะเค้าตอนนี้
มะละกอแพงนิดหน่อยค่ะ
อ้าวแล้วก็แค่นิดหน่อยนะก็เลยไม่ค่อยมีมา
รับต่อโอเคค่ะนักเรียนคะชนิดนี้นักเรียน
ก็
รู้จัก
ผลไม้
นะว่าผลไม้อะไรครูเอกชอบครู Arty ชอบครับ
แล้วไม้อะไรคู๋ไม่ชอบสวัสดีชอบทั้งหมดนัก
ถ้าชอบผลไม้อะไรเออคอมเม้นท์บอกอาอะไร
งั้นเดี๋ยวคลิปนี้เราไปก่อนนะคะค่ะอ่าได้
ครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเรียนกับพี่
อาร์ตี้เอ้ยพี่เอ๋กับขวดน้องอาร์ตี้กัน
ใหม่โอเคอ้าวหน้าครับผมพี่เองโอเคค่ะบ๊าย
บายค่ะผมขอบคุณสวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนครับบ๊ายบายค่ะอ่า